- Nothing great should be easy.
I'm gonna tweet that.
Right, like why should
anything great be easy?
Fuck man, honestly, like,
you know this is where
the most of the money I've made in my life
is been between the delta
of my marketing talent,
and the person's stake of their product.
I'm playing the arbitrage of the gray,
not of the black and white math.
This is a $215 million company.
As the offspring of me, the human,
being the top of the funnel.
Now I'm both.
Ya know, I'm both.
Meaning I could be the front man
and I'm the COO, not just the CEO
I'm operational, I'm in it.
But so are you.
(inspirational music)
- The process that we create
is a three prong process.
Education might be the only entry
where we don't listen to
the user, the end user.
Everybody else is obsessed
with the end user.
You are obsessed with your clients,
and how they experiencin'
your product
- My man, I got,
I got real news for you man,
people out here aren't listening
to the end user, either.
- Really?
- Yeah, man.
I sit in, like, that's what marketing is.
Like, Coca-Cola sits in a
room and they're deciding,
and they have all this
information from the end user,
and they're not using it.
To your point, when somebody
listens to the end user,
and is obsessed with the end
user, they become Amazon.
But, ya know, I become me
when I'm just listening to the end user.
But, man, listen,
education's got not chance.
Government's got no
chance, you know, like,
but in business, ideologically,
it's supposed to do better,
unfortunately, it's not how humans roll.
Empathy is a rare trait.
It's a rare trait.
I think way too many people
doing good right now,
are scared to show any
part of what they need
because they're worried
that people are gonna
be cynical to them.
I needed to do a lot of things
before I started putting
out a lotta content,
and on my cost, and so I don't judge
people getting to a place.
So, I think that's number one.
You, You're number one, you're the engine.
- And then, everything else is secondary.
(gentle contemporary music)
- Let me tell you one of my
super, macro points of view
of why we're dealing with a lot of things
that we're dealing with
corporately and socially.
We didn't pay the piper, in
2009, when we were supposed to.
I believe accountability,
and I believe in those kinda things.
And so, this is a sneaker
collaboration I did with K-Swiss,
clouds and dirt.
It's the framework of my life.
My clouds are my why.
What am I trying to do?
What's my aspirations?
The silly ones, like the
chase of buying the jets
or being the most inspirational, impactful
entrepreneur of a generation.
And the dirt is the reason I
have respect from the people
that work for me, because I'm in my shit.
I love the dirt, I respect.
Ya know, people ask me, a lot
of times, who inspires you?
Or, who inspired you?
And they always want, like, the Steve Jobs
and, fuckin', horseshit answer.
The person that inspires
me is the emails I get
from the single parent who's
holding down three jobs
and gets value out of my flipping content
and is literally emailing
me from picking up something
at a curb at 12:30 in the morning
'cause they're gonna sell
it for 27 dollars, tomorrow,
on Facebook, and marketplace,
and they're thanking me
for making that video
because the extra hundred bucks a month
is meaningful to their family.
Like that's real life.
The dirt is grossly underestimated.
People wanna leave the
dirt, get out of it.
And, I wanna, as good
things are happening to me,
I'm trying to go deeper
in the fuckin' dirt.
(upbeat inspirational music)
(applauding)
Thanks for having me.
Take care.
- That was awesome, thank you so much.
- Thank you for having me.
Such a pleasure.
- Thank you, yeah, awesome.
- There is no situation
that I'm not prepared for emotionally,
and I keep building leverage to be able to
bring more value to the other
person than I require of them.
That's it, in life.
Let alone running my business.
(upbeat inspirational music)
I come from the dirt.
Ya know, I came from zero.
I lived in a studio apartment
with nine family members.
We lived real humble real long.
My entire college friendship network,
half of'em are on welfare,
like, I come from a dirt place.
I value that dirt, and I think
one of the vulnerabilities of corporations
is they get fat, and
countries, they get fat.
(upbeat inspirational music)
- Ya know, maybe it was thousands.
Like, maybe, 30 to $40,000
before someone says,
"What are you, what are you doing with?"--
- Sure thing, well, Big Dog's
here, so that's all my time.
So if you have any questions,
please don't hesitate to email me.
- Oh, thanks Jordan.
- Thanks brother.
Appreciate it, bud,
- Thank you.
thank you.
- Hello guys.
How are you?
- Good.
(upbeat music)
- The way that your grand
pappy blindly believed
in radio and television,
I believe in Facebook,
for the top of the funnel,
period, end of story.
It's why most of you are probably here.
I got you with top of the funnel branding.
I surely didn't get you here
on fate of fuckin' radio and television,
or direct mailing.
(laughing)
That's what's so meta about this, right?
Like, sometimes people come in
here and they're like "Nah."
I'm like, "Why'd you pay ten thousand?"
Top of the funnel branding.
Provide value at scale, right?
TV companies in 1987 priced commercials,
at midnight to five in the morning,
not enough for what it was
worth and people exploited that.
It's why it worked.
Got it? Facebook.
Let me give you an example.
Being in business since 1979
has one incredible advantage
and one incredible disadvantage.
It's called being in business since 1979.
So the disadvantage is
you're holding on to radio
and television based on
whoever's older than you
in the family or you
grew up in the propaganda
of believing it 'cause
it's what got us there.
Right?
- Right.
The advantage is you have a
lot of satisfied costumers.
Literally, if I was your
partner, I'd be like,
"Okay, cool, nice trip to New York,
"we go back home, we call, email,
"or reach out to the last 500
customers that were pumped,
"and we literally
demographically break them down."
I wanna see a white family.
I wanna see an Asian family.
I wanna see a Latino family.
I wanna see an African American family.
Male, a female, 80 years old,
60 year olds, 40 year old, 20 year old.
I break them all down.
I go film them with with my fuckin' phone,
and go tell us, did you like us?
"I like 'em."
I go back home, I run the ad,
and I run an Indian family
against Indian Americans.
This is so absurdly effective.
That's way better than the bullshit,
thirty second commercial you're running
on fuckin' remnant
inventory, on fucking cable.
When did we get these pens?
- They're cool.
- They been,
that's day one stuff, bro.
- We've had this day one?
I don't think so, Orsini.
I've never seen this pen.
Did we pay for it?
- We'll getcha.
- I bartered'em out.
- Go 'head.
- We better bartered these.
I need to see the barter list.
(gentle piano music)
When I produce content,
I'm not looking for what's happening
on the back end of that content.
I know admiration and
awareness will happen.
And if you make that switch
and know what you actually
want to happen, will happen.
Listen, life is, it gets so
amazingly, simply, interesting.
Like, if you give,
karma is the most
practical thing on Earth.
(piano music)
Do you know who loses when
the internet comes along?
Everybody in the middle.
So either you understand that and adjust,
or you feel the ramifications.
Hello?
How are ya, brother?
Of course, let's rock 'n roll.
I'm just very solution oriented.
Like, complaining and dwelling
never leads to anything I believe in.
It never does.
You don't fuckin' know what's going on
behind somebody's closed doors.
I've not been able to get rid of that.
That's how I live my life.
Ya know, Kate Spade looked
super pumped, to me.
Anthony Bourdain was a
super rich, white dude.
Super famous, rich, white dude.
Ya know, so, there's obvious unfairness
and then there's the
scalable hidden unfairness.
And I just don't judge, I'm
just not in the mood of judging.
So, when I talk about
stop crying and hustling,
I feel like anything
somebody's complaining about,
somebody else could also
complain about something.
And, I don't know why we have
so much judgment in the air
that somebody has it better or worse.
And I feel like there's a lot
of things one can control.
I'm a big believer that
if you don't like the game
you're playing, leave it.
(upbeat music)
Rockin'?
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
- How are you? James.
Good to see you.
James how are you?
- Salvatore.
- Sup, man, Trenton.
- Trenton.
- Nice to meet ya.
- Michael.
- Gary, this is my brother Dylan,
he can't hear you so--
- Dylan,
such a pleasure.
- Yeah, awesome.
- How was your day?
- [Gary] It's goin' super well.
- Awesome.
So, we're here.
- Yes.
- Came out
all the way from Miami.
Spoke to you on the podcast--
- Yep.
- a year ago.
You remember, we talked
about social media marketing?
If you don't mind, I just have,
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm just gonna
look off this.
First off, I want to thank you so much
for letting us come, it's crazy.
I envisioned this ever since
we talked on the podcast.
Like, seriously, ask him--
- Like, he's serious, man.
- We all talked about this.
- We wrote it down.
- It was on our bathroom wall,
every day.
- That's awesome,
I'm glad you guys are here.
- That's one of our goals
this year.
I like admiration more than I like money.
I don't want your money.
I want you guys to think I'm the best.
- [James] You're doing a good job at it.
- You know what I mean?
- Do you ever--
- And I don't mind you
not thinking I'm the best, at first.
I wanna be cheered when the
buzzer goes triple zero.
I don't mind being booed
in the first quarter.
Everybody else wants to be admired
being up 41 to nothing at
halftime, but they're gonna loose.
My leverage comes from, I want less.
I want less money.
- [James] Was there a point
when you did it for the money?
- Not really.
The money was a scoring mechanism
to being good at entrepreneurship,
something I thought was cool.
But then it transformed when I realized,
oh, getting the most doesn't mean,
like, you could just raise capital
and take money off the
board, but your company dies.
And then, so it transformed
into something of an ambition
of having real, long term, right?
Guys, you think I've got
something going on right now?
I'm telling you, wait 'til
the economy collapses.
I'm gonna rise like a fuckin' phoenix.
'Cause everyone else is
gonna get smoked out.
Tried and true wins.
(chattering office)
Next.
- Ready for your next?
- Yup.
What are we doin' next?
- Ready to rock next?
Let's do, we did the selfie?
It's FIFA.
- Selfie?
- No, you did it with
Kwame, so playin' FIFA now.
- What's up, my guy.
- [Travis] Half ya know
about the business.
- I love it, man, how you doin'?
- Good, good.
- Good, you doing well?
- Yeah, thanks for having me.
- Yeah, looking forward to it.
- I appreciate it.
So, okay
- You're rockin' & rollin'.
- FIFA?
- Yeah FIFA.
- My first game of FIFA, ever.
- Ever?
- Ever.
No, I mean, I played FIFA '94.
But you guys weren't born yet.
- That was--
- The first one.
- I know.
I played the first FIFA ever.
- Think we were just sayin'
- Sega Genesis.
I got to put this on?
- Yeah.
Are we going live on Twitch?
What's up, Twitch?
So I'm playing my first,
this is this FIFA 2018?
I'm playin' my first
FIFA 2018 match, here.
I'm pretty exited about it.
You wanna give a one second
bio of who you're about
and how you got here,
bartered out the sneaker game.
I love people that--
- Absolutely.
- figure it out. Go ahead.
- Absolutely,
so Brady Benzz on Twitch, two Zs.
I got the Gary V. 003s, I bought 45 pairs.
We struck a deal to
get a game on my Twitch
and his Twitch, and make this happen.
So, here we are, boys.
(upbeat piano music)
- [Travis] This is the one
that I started on the street
two for $1. (laughing)
- So good.
Two spears, $1.
That's what I did out of a
wooden pickle cart in 2008.
- I love you, so much.
So after not getting a job at Nike,
that's kind of how I started, right?
- I love you.
- You know what, you Tweeted
something about a week ago,
you were saying cucumbers--
- Are underrated?
- Are underrated.
- I thought you were
pluggin' us for the episode.
- No, it's just a rant, no
joke, this is what happened.
This is how my Twi, that's not how my,
my Twitter game is fuckin' fresh.
I ate, like four cucumbers
at, like, 7 a.m.,
like, "These are delicious."
I'm like, you know what?
Cucumbers are fuckin' underrated.
People thought I meant the cucumber emoji.
(laughing)
- Oh wow, really?
It's funny, they--
- Anyway man, honestly, bro,
for me, the biggest thing about this
is this is what I want kids to think
entrepreneurship is.
- You just fuckin'
with my ideas.
This is what I care about.
- Me too.
Everybody want's to fuckin'
come up with the Uber of fucking waffles,
and I'm gonna build an app.
And, like, I'm build the next
sneaker fuckin' marketplace,
and everybody's just
so fuckin' impractical.
Like, know what you know, and fuckin',
put your fuckin' head down for
a decade, and then look up.
- Yes sir.
- But nobody wants to do that.
- That's why I wanted you to meet him
because, ya know, remember I told ya,
just the whole, like, selling pickles
out of a wooden pickle cart.
- Yeah, I fuck with that.
- People laughed at him.
Right, you know what I mean?
- By the way, that, to me,
is the most important part of the story.
The reason these kids
aren't doing anything
is 'cause they're worried
about people's judgment.
They can't be bothered
sellin' pickles outta a cart.
They're too busy trying
to get to the Hamptons,
jump on a swan and put it on Instagram.
(laughing)
- But to do that,
you gotta sell pickles for ten years.
Then you can go to the Hamptons
and sit on a swan
- Then you can fuckin'
own a house in the Hamptons.
- Exactly!
- You were executing.
- But they're so lazy.
My god, I executed too,
nobody heard a peep from me for 12 years.
- Yeah, and then you go. (laughing)
- I, fuckin', put my head down,
and was in a liquor store,
every, fucking, day.
Didn't have a word to say to nobody.
Everybody's tryin'--
- - Cryin'.
- to come out--
Everybody's tryin--
- Probably.
to come out--
the gate and say I'm an entrepreneur.
Like, cool, I'm a basketball player.
- Do you make money, entrepreneur?
(laughing) Like, literally,
people go print 10 tee-shirts
with some word and decide
that's their Supreme.
Right, and they're like,
"Yo, I'm an entrepreneur."
I'm like, "Cool, I'm an actor."
(laughing)
Ya know, like, do you get paid?
Are you winning?
(piano music)
- This is how IG started.
- Story of life.
- And the world's next.
- Stars life.
- My brother Gary V.
- Pickles for life, eat 'em.
(laughing) Eat 'em.
Alright, fellas, have a good night.
Nothing great should be easy.